[Musique]
le pire moment de ma vie c'est ce que
dit la maire socialiste de canteleu qui
a été placé en garde à vue la semaine
dernière lors d'une opération
anti-stupéfiants seine maritime je suis
innocente jeune et je ne connais pas si
personne je ne suis pas en contact avec
elle je n'ai pas je ne les ai ni et
dénis couvert ni accompagné jeu mais vos
questions elles continuent d'entretenir
cela je pense que vraiment c'est ignoble
ce que vous faites est ce que vous allez
vous soumettre au vote des militants oui
je participerai à ce congrès parce que
les républicains ont écarté la primaire
ces personnes essaient d'entrer en
contact avec moi par personne interposée
non mais ce que je veux dire madame la
maire madame là bien sûr maintenant vous
devez définir il est trop de tensions
dans notre pays pour en rajouter
aujourd'hui on a besoin d'un président
qui traite les problèmes qui apporte des
solutions qui soient crédibles c'est ce
président là que je veux être ici mort
ce n'est pas de gaulle si moore c'est
charles maurras alors le nom est un peu
oublié aujourd'hui mais c'est qui c'est
le théoricien l'extrême droite française
au 19e siècle c'est celui qui parlait à
l'époque du grand remplacement alors ne
parlez pas à l'époque début du banc
parler des juifs et des italiens donc
quel est le nom du parti reprend le dire
maintenant
horizon le parti que nous créions c'est
le parti qui porte ce nom d'horizon
voyage
moi je pense que c'est un peu le baiser
de la mort quand même parce que j'ai
compris qu'il avait sur deux heures de
discours annoncé qu'ils soutenaient
emmanuel macron pendant à peu près cinq
minutes et tout le reste du temps a été
consacré à pointer les deux grands
échecs de ce quinquennat c'est à dire
l'insécurité et les déficits publics oui
il y a une responsabilité des médias qui
depuis des années ont promu eric zemmour
a forcément sur votre chaîne mais lui a
jamais il n'y a pas le droit l'avenir il
a été promu il n'a pas le droit de venir
ici la séquence a été récupéré par tous
les soutiens de zéro à tel point que le
patron de france info à du milan ac à
eric zemmour et le courant de pensée
qu'il représente ne sont interdits
d'antenne à france télé eric zemmour
sera bien évidemment invités dans nos
rendez vous politique s'il se porte
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
je proposerai de renforcer la loi
gayssot en rendant inéligibles des
personnes qui sont condamnées pour
racisme pour incitation à la haine
raciale pour discrimination en fonction
de sa religion moi je serais favorable à
ce qu'on supprime cette redondance
qu'ils cessent de racketter les français
puis de leur cracher au visage 3 669
euros c'est pas rien alors non ce n'est
pas 169 euros mais 138 euros c'est vrai
que aujourd'hui il divise la famille
nationale mais on verra à l'arrivée la
campagne vous savez elle est longue
jusqu'au mois d'avril va se passer
beaucoup de choses et nous avons dit
nous qu'une chose nous n'avons qu'un
ennemi cet ennemi c'est le système c'est
emmanuel macron et son gouvernement
assène violente et filmé en plein cool
on y voit un lycéen qui veut sortir de
classe son professeur s'y opposent
le garçon qui a fait ça sera sévèrement
sanctionné mais entendu je laisse à
procès le processus se réaliser
maintenant sur le plan disciplinaire
mais il est évident qu il doit être
écartée re scolarisés très différemment
le phénomène est de plus en plus
fréquent dans les quartiers nord de
wimereux dans le pas de calais à la nuit
tombée pour éviter les policiers
présents sur le littoral les passeurs en
mêle les migrants dans les quartiers
résidentiels pour y transporter leurs
embarcations état d' alerte à nouveau
sur l'île espagnole de las palmas aux
canaries 3000 habitants ont reçu l'ordre
de se confiner la lave du volcan a
détruit une cimenterie ce qui provoque
des émanations de gaz potentiellement
toxiques un appel fort pour qu'il puisse
nous aider 1
comment essayer d'attraper les passeurs
sur tout un pan mouvant en ne bougeant
paul quiles neuilly me pilloud
communique les informations et moi je
leur transmets au niveau des services de
police on est un peu démunis on peut pas
être partout à la fois